the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the
closing ceremony of the 2021
u.s championship and u.s women's
championship
it was an amazing event this year how
much fun we had
we commentators always say this is our
favorite event and we're not just saying
that to make rex happy and tony having
jeannie happy and joy happy
the truth is with 24 players in an event
it's very different from having 10.
because 24 means more stories you got 12
boards you got more players
you got a diverse feel as well and it's
always always entertaining and this year
they brought the entertainment we saw a
history get made we'll talk about that
and of course there was the exciting
playoffs as well
leading to the title holder so it simply
was extraordinary we totally enjoyed
calling it
and look forward to next year as well
we're going to kick off the proceedings
by introducing someone who has been a
wonderful friend to our sport
without her and her husband
this all would not happen the magic of
saint louis
is due to one family one power couple
and so i'm happy to introduce dr dr
jeanne sinfield
so if rex is the godfather of american
chess does that make me the fairy
godmother
okay
hey before we go on out as as a now
international
chess author
i would like to be do a little shout out
to the people who helped me translate
this little booklet
um for those who don't know how to read
or write chess
into eight languages i wrote english
and uh wesley soa's family helped me get
filipino
uh i co-authored indonesian
christians cirilla did romanian
yasser's wife did dutch
alejandro did spanish where are you
and uh
anna zatonski found someone who could
speak german
so it was a lot of fun wasn't this a
great tournament though it's just a
great great tournament
it's a
you're looking at the at the players and
it's like the only thing i can tell to
some of the older players is watch your
back
like sam
sebian
at 20 competing against two of the top
players in the world
clarissa yip
competing against what nine times
u.s championship irena crush this was an
exciting exciting thing
this is really great well anyway
so oh one last shout out to my scout
friends i always do that 250 000 scouts
of her in the chess merit badge
i am
[Applause]
see the godfather of american chess is
always focusing on the high end
i'm growing your audience so you can
make money
so they is my pleasure
to introduce
the godfather of american chess
rex
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much you can
keep that music going if you want i'm
accustomed to it
so
what what extraordinary championships
congratulations
to all of the players
i know you all didn't get what you
wanted but you got into these events and
that alone is no mean feat
uh the u.s championship field had five
players rated over 2700
and congratulations to wesley for
winning back-to-back championships the
last time
someone won back-to-back championships
was kamsky in 2013 and 14.
only the third time in the men's game
since love albert in 1984 and 85 that a
player won back-to-back championships
now the u.s women's championship field
was equally interesting was one of the
most exciting ever carissa won against
four
former u.s champions which has never
happened in the history of u.s women's
championships
[Applause]
how does that make those four former
champions feel
so she won the event by one and a half
points
she was funnier than the commentators
and she is still in high school
payne
i want to thank the best commentary team
in the world for their amazing and
entertaining broadcast
please join me in an applause to
grandmasters chirilla sirwan and ashley
[Applause]
you know when i
you know i compliment them they think
i'm just kidding
no but i actually
yeah i mean
that's true
so randy and his team at spectrum
studios along with silverback studios
leonard you all put on the best
production broadcast ever the studio set
and mobile control room is truly
phenomenal
we couldn't do all of this
without the amazing staff
joy tony you and your team did an
outstanding job as always
this is the 13th championship it's hard
to believe that we have hosted and they
just continue to improve shannon you and
your team continue to do a marvelous job
as well by exhibiting beautifully the
artistic side of the game
i'd like to acknowledge courtney suthoff
rebecca buffington tony chen brian
flowers in our pr marketing and
communications teams
at the club and world chess hall of fame
they all truly do a great job
now in terms of our viewership i love
talking about this some of it's a little
strange we had 100 that we know of we
had 141 countries
view the championships
online including
some biggies
krzyzikistan mozambique and guyana
that was supposed to be extraordinarily
funny
but it really does depend on the
audience
we had nearly 340 000
unique viewers
and over 1.2 million viewers on youtube
and 70 000 views on twitch
there were approximately 20 million
viewer minutes
and i think a lot of that is due to our
incredible commentary team
lastly i would like to say it's been
amazing to have over the board
tournaments at the chess club this year
and i'm already looking forward to 2022.
thank you very much
thank you rex well one small correction
irina is an eight-time champ she's
looking for nine i know you're trying to
speak it into existence and i'm sure she
appreciates it
this event
it really always feels like a family
we're coming together with family and
friends
that we've seen for
years and years
and part of the reason it feels like a
family is because we're hosted like a
family and the team here is simply
extraordinary and the one word i would
give
beyond brilliant creative extraordinary
is consistency we know the quality level
is going to be high year after year
after year they try to make things
better each time and it's thanks to
people like joy bray who always ducks
the credit in the camera but we can get
a camera on her right now so the world
can see you joy
and of course the big dog he's been here
since the very beginning he was here
when the club
was rubbles
and he remember going to meet with him
the very uh beginning and seeing the
club and thinking it was never going to
happen i didn't know it would become
what it is and the expansion that it's
going to become and he continues to
oversee it so please welcome executive
director of the chess club tony rich
13 years of us championships
you guys remember last year u.s
championship because i don't
the covet pandemic really kind of put a
a curve ball i know for all of us and
last year's u.s championships were held
online very briefly i think three or
four days and everybody was in and out i
got to say hi on the webcams to a couple
of folks here and there but that was
about it
that's not what the u.s championship
should be and i'm really excited that
we're able to return to over the board
play uh this year you know the u.s
championship is is not just an
opportunity to spotlight great chess
players and the talent that they bring
but these these are the very best that
america has to offer
some of them were born here some of them
decided to make this their home
all of them are committed to making sure
that american chess continues to thrive
and i just want to say that i'm really
proud of each of each and every one of
you for your fighting spirit your
tenacity and your ability to make
america
a great chess nation so thank you all
of course
as everybody else has said there are
lots of folks to thanks for this to
thank for this event uh randy singfield
and his crew at spectrum studios uh tom
williamson kevin de pew and all the guys
over at silverback they're the
production team they're all the folks
that you see running around here with
the cameras they were the ones that were
up there in front of the players and and
trying to get those shots while the
players were looking very stoic despite
the fact that there's a camera literally
right next to their head um
you know you guys are are what helps
expand chest take it away from just the
chest dorks like myself and into a
broader audience
who can really appreciate and enjoy the
game so thanks to all of you for for
making the show so wonderful in addition
to the pr team that rex mentioned uh
kostya kavutsky was our journalist for
this event leonard otis did the the dgt
boards and photography as well as brian
adams uh austin and crystal fuller um
you know i know we joke around but it
really does take a village to produce an
event like this and i think as maurice
mentioned when it comes to consistency
it's just because we're lucky to have
such a great team so thanks to all the
folks who made it possible
so some of you may know that we had
originally intended to do world chess
hall of fame inductions at this ceremony
we have instead decided to postpone
those the world chess hall of fame
inductions will be in november of 2022
and the reason is because the two living
inductees eugene torre and judith polgar
will both be able to come to st louis in
person and receive their honors and
awards
so i'm very excited to be able to host
that in february
where the
chief curator of the world chess hall of
fame shannon bailey will have her moment
to shine so shannon i really look
forward to it i can't wait it's going to
be fun
and at this time i would like to ask rex
in genius singfield if you could please
join me on the stage we'd like to
present you um yeah shannon as well
please uh we would like to present you
with a little thank you gift for 13
years of u.s championships
[Applause]
[Music]
hi we're presenting a rex and genie with
a beautiful picture book of remarkable
moments that have happened because of
their generous support
over the last 13 years
thank you to all the staff who helped
put it together and please enjoy and
thank you so much on behalf of all the
staff
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you tony
you know we're still waiting for our
picture book
me and the commentators we want goodies
too thank you appreciate it
one of the
great things about
a tournament that is run really well
is that you don't hear any controversy
you don't hear anything from the
arbiters
just no issues
and in this event we didn't have any
i mean we would like to have a fight
breakout
and potentially somebody throw juice on
somebody else it would be really cool
for the commentators and the audience
but none of that happened it was
perfectly well run and i think it was
because
the players are probably scared of the
arbiters that we have who look like you
know
true soldiers
weren't you a soldier frank
you was yeah that's right i thought you
were well
one of those true soldiers
will
come to the stage now is international
arbiter and feed a events manager chris
byrd
[Applause]
right thank you maurice
um so in my role as chief arbiter um
usually when i come to these ceremonies
the first thing i check out is the
program
and when i see that it says
drawing of lots chris bird announces the
pairings
the first person i run to is tony rich
i say tony i don't want to be seen on
camera
and i really don't want to be talking at
all
so
tony always comes to my rescue
usually at the cost of a sarcastic
comment or two where he tells people
that i chickened out somehow
um but that's that's a really small
price to pay to not be up here
uh i guess unfortunately tonight that's
that's not happening so
here i am
um when i asked tony um for a little bit
of advice on
you know what i should do how how the
talks work
tony's advice was
just do like i do have a few drinks and
wing it
thanks man
all right so i'm gonna get to what i
need to talk about
um at some point but first
i'm going to give you a little
taste of a crisp bread visit to the
confessional booth
and
that was just worth seeing the fear in
joy's face there
when i announced that
so sadly as you heard at the opening
ceremony
we lost one of the greatest arbiters
in the world when carol jarecki passed
away in june
carol was the person
most responsible
for where i am
in the chess world today
she got me invited to my first national
scholastic event
recommended me
to various other major tournaments
and even persuaded the folks in saint
louis
to hire me to be the deputy arbiter at
the 2009 u.s championship which was
their first major event
she mentored me she guided me
she pushed me pushed me to become the
best arbiter and person
that i could be
we became great friends
made so many wonderful memories together
at all events we worked at
a week or so after carol passed away
john hartman the editor of chess life
emailed me and asked me if i'd write an
article
on carol
i really wish that i could say you'll be
able to read that article in an upcoming
issue of chess life
but after thinking about it for a few
days i declined and i said no
my reason was there wasn't a way
that i could even begin to
do justice to just how much carol meant
to me are all the amazing things she'd
done for me
carol
i love you i miss you
a few days ago
i was asked to represent usgs
to say thank you to everyone for hosting
the 2021 u.s
and u.s women's championships
given my love for public speaking
i immediately said yes
after thinking about it for a while
i was like
oh heck what have i done
i realized with all the amazing work
that's been done here since that first
major event in 2009
there's no possible way that talking up
here on the stage for a couple of
minutes
can never do justice
to everything that these folks have done
for us chess
can't possibly be done
but since my boss asked me to do it
i'm up here
and coincidentally
she's also called carol
so
thank you to rex and jeannie sinkville
joy bray
tony rich
rebecca emily
all the fantastic staff of the world
chess hall of fame
the st louis chess club for once again
providing your world-class
organizational skills
world-class production
world-class facilities
world-class conditions
world-class prize funds
um world-class production
broadcast
commentary teams
and yes thank you for here at even
hiring
world-class arbiters
and for including me too
and by the way it's maya's birthday on
thursday so happy birthday maya make
sure someone gets her a drink at some
point
thank you also for your continued
desiring commitment
usually going well out of your way to
always provide everyone who plays in
your events
whatever they need to make sure they
perform at their best
at every players meeting tony rich
always tells the players
he wants this to be the best event
they've ever been to
he's not just saying that because it's
part of his spiel
he and the rest of the chess club
really mean that from the bottom of
their hearts
so thank you
for making the u.s championships
the greatest national championships in
the world
on behalf of u.s chess and chess in the
united states
thank you
last but not least it's my greatest
pleasure
to announce that in prince paul
us chess and the st louis chess club
have reached an agreement for them to
also host the 2022
u.s championship and 2022 u.s women's
championships thank you
[Music]
chris that was a fantastic speech let me
be the first to tell you
i've been trying to get the arbiters to
come inside
our broadcasts
speak in the interview chair that the
players go to and i was always trying to
get chris to speak and he said no no now
you're in trouble
after that speech you're definitely
going to be on the show regular on the
show
and we appreciate you please everyone
acknowledge chris who was the chief
arbiter of the u.s women's
and also frank guadalupe who told me 23
years in the army
soldier
who was the chief arbiter of the open
and maya meyers who was the chief the
deputy arbiter of both please stand and
be acknowledged
thank you for all the work you do
the tournament was amazing it was
fantastic it was quite the show let's
take a look at a few of the highlights
[Music]
the 2021 u.s chess championship and the
u.s women's chess championships were
back live and in person in saint louis
the best of the best from around the
country put on a spectacle in the
capital of chess in america the u.s
women's championship started off quickly
with katarina nymsova taking an early
lead hoping to take home her first ever
title after over three years away from
the sport and for the first half of the
event it looked like she was well on her
way to doing just that however young
phenom carissa yip had other plans once
carissa took the lead she never looked
back going on a five win streak taking
down four former champs on her way to
being crowned this year's u.s women's
champion the u.s chess championship was
a star-studded affair with some of the
top players in the world competing for
their national title the standings
throughout the event were neck and neck
with multiple lead changes and a nearly
constant multiplayer tie at the top
veterans ray robson and alex lenderman
made strong showings and looked poised
to capitalize on their opportunities
however slowly but surely sleeping
giants woke with favorites wesley sow
and a surging fabiano caruana ending the
event tied for first with the young sam
sebian forcing a playoff for the title
once the dust settled a victorious
wesley so emerged after defeating
fabiano carawana and drawing sam sevien
to win a second consecutive u.s
championship title st louis shines
bright as the capital of chess in
america and will be back to host future
chess players champions and
championships for years to come
[Applause]
where else in chess do you see that kind
of production quality
like where else
please give a hand to silverback and
spectrum for the awesome awesome work
that they do they make us look
good
just amazing that's that's like espn
worthy right there good stuff
i think wesley won the last game though
right against sam that was the only
little thing i noticed but
don't worry about it we'll talk about it
kevin
well
we have our worthy winners a worthy
prize winner standing on the podium
there was a separation
between the bronze the silver and the
gold
and we're going to first begin with the
u.s
women's championship
this third place winner has been a
multi-multi champion she's literally one
of the great legends of our sport she'll
be a first ballot hall of famer someday
she continues to show her fighting
spirit of course she's from brooklyn so
what would you expect
she is
indeed
one of the most worthy players to have
won a championship she came
with her a game this time didn't quite
get all the way but she did come in
third place
please welcome to the stage grand master
irina crush
[Applause]
[Applause]
irina of course expects only the
championship trophy but she is a fighter
continues to fight to the end each and
every time
and
this third place finish
one of her top tier finishes just
represents what she always does that she
fights
every single tournament so thank you so
much irina
[Applause]
and in second place a newcomer to the
competition but i think we're going to
see this young lady for years and years
to come
very first time you come into a
competition usually you'd be nervous
scared worried will i be able to deliver
she had none of those butterflies that
we could tell she also was quite
rambunctious in the
chair when we were interviewing her i
had to be on my p's and q's her coach
was is christian carilla and he had to
keep his mouth shut a couple of times as
well as she pushed back when he uh
started talking a little bit of trash
in second place with a fantastic
performance in her maiden event
gulruk
tokyo jonova
not that
women's grandmaster by the way
as i said she had a fabulous performance
winning many games
she will certainly be in this tournament
for years to come she had a great poise
and to finish ahead of four former
champions is a real statement to
just how well she played
she will be
certainly one to watch as she continues
to improve congratulations
go mizzou
and now it's time
this event saw something special as rex
mentioned it had never happened before
in the storied history of the women's
game
never has one person defeated four
former champions
in the event never imagine that it
happened twice before in
1993 and 1997 in the open only twice
defeating four former champions uh
this had been accomplished benjamin did
it shibalov did it but again in the
women's game it had never been done so
we got to see history in the making and
she did it
in style she lost a bad game in round
five and that number five
she said okay i'm gonna show you guys
something and won five games in a row
before drawing the last game just simply
incredible performance
a one for the ages
and she's only 18.
you guys better watch out
she's
got more championships in the making but
her first one ever
welcome to the stage the winner of the
u.s women's championships
karissa yipp
she's an international master by the way
she's playing the grand master title
will not elude her for long she can will
be a force
in this event incredible talent
absolutely stupendous performance she
won by the way by a full point and a
half
that's not easy in this field
carissa if you will
please say a few words
hi guys
this is my first time ever giving a
speech
so uh please forgive me if i
sound like i'm choking up here or
dying
it's fine
um first off i have to give a big thank
you to rex and janie
i honestly feel so lucky i got to grow
up in such a bright era for american
chess where there's just so much support
for the players
and especially young players
you guys have done so much work for the
u.s championships of course but
like the u.s juniors as well
and your support with like the castro
chess foundation and the young stars
program has been
really tremendous for me and my group as
a chess player so
thank you guys for that
um
congratulations on your indefinite to
the hall of fame well deserved
[Applause]
i also want to thank the st louis chess
club and everyone who's worked so hard
to put this event together the
commentators
uh special shout out to maurice who
you know after losing that terrible game
in round five
roasted the heck out of me and you know
got me back on my game though so
thank you maurice
the tournament directors staff the
production team
i know it's been like 10 times harder
with covit but
you guys did an amazing job
everything was run so smoothly the
atmosphere was amazing
and this tournament has just always been
my favorite to play in because everyone
at the club is so nice and sweet and
welcoming
um
i also wanna give a shout out to my
opponents
i remember like the first time i played
uh i was 12 2016 u.s women's
uh i got the wild card i think i was
just so an odd to be playing with
all of all the best women players in the
country
um
i grew up like following this tournament
i watched commentary every day ever
since i was like eight or something and
it's my favorite tournament couldn't
believe i was finally here
and
that first time i got totally smashed
got very lucky in some games but overall
awful performance by me totally
outplayed and demolished
but it even mattered to me because like
tobio me was still freaking out i got to
play against like irina anna tatev
and also i was like 10 feet away from
fabiano carijuan and wesley slow which
was
i was star-strucked
and even though it's like five years
later there's still a part of me
that's so excited to play against my
idols the people who i looked up to
growing
up this tournament was really difficult
every single game was a battle
um everyone made me work for it
they say that the best friends you have
are the ones who push you be the best
version of yourselves and won't accept
anything less so thank you to my
opponents for being that friend for me
okay
uh and of course thank you to all my
coaches i wouldn't be the player i am
today without
any of them every single one has made a
serious difference for my chest a
special shout out to the casper of chess
foundation which i mentioned before
and youngstar's program
the support and training has been
invaluable for my growth as a chess
player
and i mean i gotta meet with gary
kasparov like twice a year which is so
crazy motivated me like 10 times more to
be better
okay finally
i want to thank my friends and family
i know my friends back home are watching
probably laughing at me as we speak
but thank you guys for cheering me on
and texting and calling after every
single game
and of course a huge shout out to my
parents
i love you guys um my parents have both
done so much for me made so many
sacrifices for sake of my chess career
and i wouldn't be here without them
literally
so
special shout out to my dad who's
curious in the audience he's recording
[Applause]
he brings me to all my tournaments he's
been my biggest support since the
beginning and i couldn't have won it
without him
this is truly the highlight of my chess
career i never imagined i'd be up here
but i couldn't be happier can't wait to
be back next year
the u.s women's
chess champion for 2021 international
master chrissy if everybody give her
another hand please
thanks for giving me credit partial
credit for why you won by the way
i i just hang on to those little things
and she spoke of family
you know it really
feels like a family each and every time
we come in the importance of family in
our success
their players here i know
credit the same
and one of them is
the third place winner for the u.s
open
uh he's he's been
good for a while he's been good
and he's sort of been in the shadows
waiting for some breakout performances
in this tournament he showed his heart
after losing an extremely difficult game
i think it went 140 moves
that was a long tough fight before he
finally lost that game and what did he
do after that loss
came back and won the next two and then
managed to tie for first
and lose in a tie break
no shame in the game losing in a tie
break to fabiano caruana and wesley so
so the deserving
third place winner international grand
master
sam sevion
[Applause]
sam is that one of our top juniors
i think he gets to drink alcohol shortly
because he's going to turn 21.
so we won't be calling him a junior
anymore
but he certainly has that youthful
exuberance and optimism great fighting
spirit
thank you for regarding us with your
game sam
[Applause]
and it was a tournament of comebacks
really i mean watching players lose and
then not wilt that's the fighting spirit
you want to have when you play chess i
saw it even with players who didn't
stand on the podium
i would mention tatev abrahamian as one
of those players
who started off terribly and then came
back with some great wins and showed
that she could still play and ended up i
believe tying for fourth am i correct
time for fourth place
not easy
not easy to do when you start off badly
it's hard chess when you lose a game you
could you know you feel the pain i know
what that's like
i knew what that was like over and over
and over and over
it's tough and in this event we saw one
of the superstars of our game the number
two player on the planet
actually playing badly not like himself
and then losing two in a row and we said
that's it it's over
no chance for him
and yet somehow he pulled himself up by
the bootstraps
and won a game and then won another one
and then he drew one and then he won
another one and suddenly he was tied for
first and then he was just just a move
or two away from winning the whole thing
and had to go to the playoffs and then
he lost the first game in the playoffs
and then he bounced back again in one
wasn't enough as there was one player
who did better than him but he showed
his incredible fighting spirit why it is
that he fought for the world chess
championship
back in 2018 why he's one of the major
stars of our sport
the second place finisher grand master
fabiano caruana
[Applause]
i thought i was going to give him a few
words to say but i'll say them for him
fabi's a great friend
i picked fabi to win the tournament so
fabi you gotta
do better next time
for me not for you
and i and uh thank you so much of course
fabi a great player and we'll be back
next year
thank you bobby
well the u.s championship is all about
crowning a single champion they were
back in the day when they used to tie in
three ways and all no no we don't like
that that's
i had some ideas in my head about how
what to compare it to but i'll leave it
alone
the
event is all about a single champion at
the very end
and it wasn't easy for this champion
he's actually won it twice before
both times
coming in
uh the first time he also had a playoff
the second time he came in clear first
he was the reigning champion
from 2020
this year it was clear it was not easy
at all there were so many tough fighters
in the event and he predicted it would
require plus three to win the event that
is three more wins than losses and it
was actually plus two that gotten them
in a playoffs but
as he's shown time and time again he has
the incredible tenacity the
determination
the skill the speed
and the genius to overcome his
opposition
and he is indeed the deserving champion
a back-to-back champion the first time
uh since
2014 with godikomski
and since 84.85 with lev albert first
time
in 27 years to win the championships
back to back is truly a fantastic feat
that not many people except the great
ones can say and so let's introduce to
the stage a great one the 2021 us
open champion u.s champion
wesley soh
wesley is one of the top
seven players in the world
he is the reigning fisher nine fisher
random champion chestnine 60 champ
he gets the championship jacket which
will be etched
with the
u.s champion logo
quite soon
they they still have the tag on that one
it's so fresh
but indeed a great champion continues to
be a star of our game
and will continue to be for many years
to come
i know his family is here as well
are you trying to hide the tag
just button it
all right it'll work out in some way
they don't get everything right here
nevertheless he's the champ wesley
please come
and say a few words
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
hello everyone
i just want to
say how happy i am to be here
uh i i don't win too many events often
so it feels
it feels surreal just standing here so
i'd like to thank
a lot of people and i'd like to thank
everyone who made this event possible i
don't know all you guys names but
i'll do my best i'm sure i'll miss them
but first i'd like to
say a big thank you to the thinkfield
family tourex and genie
thingfield for giving the us chess
championship and women's a home
so thank you very much
i
i
yeah amongst many other things uh that
you did for usgs i'd also like to thank
my mother lotis
she's been with me every single day i've
been a chess professional for seven and
a half years now
although it feels like longer but she's
been with me every day
and uh thank you to all your support and
and i feel like winning this tournament
comes from both of us
i
i'd also like to thank the usgs
federation
a lot of players are moving to the
united states and the tournaments are
getting tougher every year
so
i i feel it's it's good to keep you
sharp so thank you to the usgs
federation
uh thank you to our chief arbiters
uh
frank
thanks for all the work that you do
and
uh chris bird also
my friend uh
thank you for cheering me up and wishing
me good luck every every during critical
games
i knew you were rooting for me and
thank you also too
thank you to maya mayers
thanks for being there every day and for
working hard
i'd also like to thank uh
the
director of the chess club tony rich
executive director sorry
also to the wonderful joy bray who've
been here every single time
with rex making sure everything's
organized
thank you very much
thank you also to rebecca buffington and
the world chess hall of fame
uh it just it just feels so nice to be
back in saint louis and see a lot of
friendly faces
last year has been very difficult for
for me but for everyone i guess so it's
good to have over the board back uh
thank you to
the the commentators of course uh
thanks to maurice
for keeping us all entertained now where
did he go
oh there you go
sorry i thought you'd be standing
somewhere
thank you also to yasser and to
christian shirilla
for
me i mean no one will be watching the
games without you guys so thank you
uh also to the saint louis chess club
and uh wonderful staff members
i don't know all their names i know ryan
or
i i i know jonathan also emily uh
yeah thank you
also sean
alva shannon daly i remember in 2018 in
think field cup after such a horrible
tournament and finishing last place you
were there to cheer me up so i never
forget a kind word
so
also the coach of the st louis
university
[Laughter]
yeah alejandro ramirez yeah we
we played a few times just
i'm terrible with names
and also last but not least thanks to
the spectrum studios my friend kevin
uh kevin duggan also thank you to the
photographers here
i guess
austin thank you uh
leonard
and i don't know your friend's name
but anyway you know what i mean
but
yeah it's i just want to say thanks to
everyone so nice to be back here in
saint louis i i feel like i didn't play
the best chess in the tournament so
uh i'm not sure my win here is the serve
but i'll take any win
any time of the day
actually i wanna say yesterday i was
watching sam shanklin's game
and i think around 3 p.m or 3 30 i
stopped watching
because i thought he was gonna lose
so i stopped watching my game and i was
preparing already to pack my things and
uh
and uh plan whatever to do on the rest
day
and then i checked again 5 p.m and i
thought that he was holding the game so
thanks for giving us an exciting playoff
and
thank you
[Applause]
the u.s champ
wesley so
everybody
you know it's often said that chess
players are arrogant
no no way well you have champions like
wesley so and
you hear his remarks people like fabiano
caruana nicer people you'll never meet
sam savion as well
uh
the classy women who play in this event
it's great to see
the personalities it's great to see the
modesty doesn't mean they're not
confident
sometimes cocky but certainly
great people to talk about to cheer for
and to enjoy their games it's a lot of
hard work that goes into being a chess
player and it's brutal this emotional
toll can be difficult but
i just want to tell the players in the
event i'm a fan i'm a fan each and every
time we enjoy talking about your games
yasser and christian it was
amazing as usual
christian took care of the host chair
today and did a heck of a job and not
today but throughout the whole event did
a heck of a job his first time so please
congratulate christian
he was a star he was a stud
and yesterday
we've been og's for a minute
are we getting any younger
we're not getting any older they're
gonna wheel us out on a wheelbarrow
before we stop this stuff it's been
great fun thanks everyone for joining us
2022 will be running back more the same
but today we're gonna party we're gonna
get the chairs out the way please enjoy
the food and the drink and the music by
dj nunez thank you everyone see you next
year
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the
saint louis chess club any reproduction
or distribution of this content without
the express written consent of the st
louis chess club is prohibited
you